so right before Avengers infinity war
came out they released a ton of VA TV
spot trailers and we're starting to kind
of see the same thing with Deadpool now
that it's less than a week away and as
long as they keep releasing them I'll
keep showing them to you and breaking
them down
I was nice for me dude
this is a new TV spot trailer but
unfortunately it doesn't really have any
new footage this is more of just an
action trailer to try to get you excited
for the movie to come out and it starts
off with Deadpool's best impression of
LeBron James but it's also funny to note
that the very first scene in this new
trailer is him saying hello America
missed me while he's standing in front
of a hillside amusement park sign which
is in Canada I'm sure this is just
classic Deadpool humor or maybe he's
right on the border of America
either way the trailer does its job it
gets me more excited to see Deadpool -
that comes out in less than a week now
I'm super pumped for Deadpool - I'm
excited to see all the humor that
they're gonna throw into the movie just
like they did the first one and I'm
really excited to see cable and the
comics cable is just this insanely
strong character how strong well
cable fought Wolverine to a stalemate he
defeated Captain America in hand-to-hand
combat and he defeated Falcon Red Hulk
and Iron Man using just brute force and
wit so he's taken down some champs again
Deadpool 2 comes out in less than a week
if you're going to see it let me know in
the comments below and tell me what
you're most excited to see about
Deadpool - if you enjoyed the video hit
that like button and be sure to
subscribe to my channel to join the wolf
gang and to be entered into our speaker
giveaway the rest of the details of the
giveaway are in the description section
below thank you so much for watching
woof woof much about this Cable fella
but I guarantee he hasn't killed as many
people as melanoma has Deadpool -